[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIM BRAY: Hey, everyone.
My name is Tim Bray.
I'm with the identity
group at Google.
And with me today, I have Eric
Sachs who's the lead PM in the
identity group and sort of our
thought leader on this whole
identity and login stuff.
And you don't have to dig very
hard to uncover a deep level
of dissatisfaction in the user
experience of the internet and
how people feel about passwords,
and how this makes
everybody's life online
a little less pleasant
than it could be.
So Eric, how bad is it really?
ERIC SACHS: How bad is it?
Well, bad enough, and
getting worse.
So there are different
forms of bad.
[INAUDIBLE]
thought is on Google's site,
we did a blog post a couple
months ago where we mentioned
that we see periods of time
where a single hijacker using
stolen passwords based on
password reuse is trying to
break into a million different
Google accounts every
day for weeks.
That's just a single guy.
And the reason that it's getting
worse and worse is
password reuse.
The hackers have realized,
you know what?
They don't need to break
into Google anymore.
And hopefully most of
you all know this.
They go on break into other
websites that are less secure.
And the press has started to
talk about this more and more.
And those of us who run websites
are probably starting
to feel more and more
embarrassed.
To be honest, Google and a
foundation called the OpenID
Foundation, we want to ratchet
up that embarrassment level a
little bit.
There's actually a website the
OpenID Foundation is putting
together called
accountchooser.net.
And if you go there, you'll
notice on the left is a link
for this user's page which has
a lot of visuals and text
explaining the password reuse
problem because we find, for
the average non-technical
user, they don't really
appreciate what's happening.
And for those of you watching
who don't, the general idea is
that the attackers don't go
directly to banking websites,
Google, social networks and try
to break past all of our
security layers because
we have lots.
Instead, they go to websites
where they might be able to
even break into the back end
of the websites, get the
password lists and email lists
of these websites.
And now that they have those,
great, now they can go and try
to use those against websites
that have more valuable
information.
So the first problem is this
password reuse thing is making
it easier for these hijackers
to get into accounts.
The other worst thing is that
they're making more and more
money from it, which is
the next thing this
website talks about.
It gives the example of the
hackers sending fake mails to
the friends and contacts of
someone whose accounts they've
taken over, tricking them into
saying, oh, I was traveling.
I lost my wallet.
I can't pay the hotel bill.
I know we haven't
talked a while.
Will you wire me money?
And people do.
It's embarrassing for them.
They lose a lot of money.
It's embarrassing for you.
Your friends are tricked.
And this is because
of password reuse.
And if you read the press, our
best advice to end users is,
well, use a different password
at every website.
And I don't know about you all,
but I'm embarrassed if
that's the best advice
we can give.
And so this is where Google and
other companies are trying
to help websites move away from
that model into using
identity providers.
TIM BRAY: Well, I think we've
got pretty good consensus that
the best way out of the password
trap is to go to
federated identity and use
identity providers rather than
building your own fragile
infrastructure on your own site.
So is it that easy?
You just push a button
and you're
doing federated identity?
ERIC SACHS: Yeah, I really wish
it was, to be honest.
As soon as we get to the point
where it's that easy, we're
going to be more aggressively
getting this message out to
the industry to put more
pressure on websites to make
that change.
But I'd say right now, there are
two classes of websites.
One class of websites who gets
fire from identity providers
not just for getting rid of
passwords, but actually they
get other values from API
integration from these
identity providers.
So social login is a big
example, enterprise API
integration is another one.
For those websites, sure, it's
a lot of work to support
identity providers.
But they got a lot of bang for
the buck from it, not just
getting rid of passwords.
A lot of other API
[? probably. ?]
But what about all the
rest of the websites?
They may be just trying to get
out of the password business.
They're not ready to do all that
fancy API integration.
So for them, a lot of work.
Not as much value.
And in fact, what we find is
they don't even recognize
upfront necessarily
how hard it is.
There are hard problems that
lead to a lot of users calling
help desks.
And that drives websites
crazy because it
drives up their costs.
There are also really hard
questions and edge cases to do
with what we refer to
as account linking.
So you may have seen
this yourself.
You go to a website
that added one of
these buttons for login.
You click it, and the website
says, oh, you have an existing
account here.
Why don't you go through this
wizard to bind your existing
account to this new account
and connect them together?
Building those flows and
handling all the edge cases is
a lot of work.
Now fortunately, there are
vendors who are starting to
provide software and services
to make this easier.
So in fact, this same website,
accountchooser.net, it has a
link for website owners.
And down at the bottom, a link
to more information about
identity providers and
vendors who can help.
And we're getting better
and better at this.
But not to the point
that it's easy.
We're also doing further
optimizations to the protocols
like OpenID Connect and other
tricks to address some of
these user experience problems
and make it simple.
But to be honest, there is
still some ways to go.
TIM BRAY: And bear in mind, the
cost of not doing it, as
you pointed out, is
still pretty high.
ERIC SACHS: Yes.
TIM BRAY: So where
do you start?
What's the first step?
ERIC SACHS: So there
at least there is
some pretty good news.
This website we referred
to, it's called
accountchooser.net.
And you might be wondering,
OK, well what the heck is
Account Chooser itself?
What we've found is that to
address these problems a
website is having, I mentioned
one set of problems is users
calling help desks
with confusion.
A lot of that is around
the user experience.
And so the industry, actually
a bunch of what we like to
call backstabbing competitors,
Google and others, have
actually developed a user
experience we're happy with
that actually helps a website
who's purely password based,
not doing anything with
identity providers.
And once actually a website is
[INAUDIBLE] that, they tend to
really like that, then it's
actually pretty easy for them
to do staged deployment of
identify providers in a more
controlled manner.
But before we talk about that,
Tim, why don't you just run
through a demo?
TIM BRAY: Sure.
Yeah, this is one of my
favorite little demos.
I've got this little website
called favcolor.net
that does one thing.
It remembers your
favorite color.
And when I go there,
you see this thing.
This is not favcolor branded
except in the right side of
the screen there.
This is the cross-account
Account Chooser.
It remembers all the accounts
I've used to log in to one
thing or another.
So you can see I have
my personal address,
textuality.com.
And I can log into that
using Facebook.
And it went to the
Facebook IDP.
And it says, oh, I know
your favorite color.
It's this nice royal purple.
We'll just turn it into a lurid
pink and save that.
So that's now my favorite
color, a lurid pink.
So I can switch over and log in
to that same textuality.com
email address via Google as
opposed to via Facebook.
And it goes to Google.
And pop, there I am logged in
with that sort of puce,
whatever favorite color.
So what you're seeing there is
one click sign in with the aid
of an identity provider.
Now, Account Chooser, as Eric
says, works even if you don't
have an identity provider.
It still helps you log in with
passwords and so on.
But I want to show you one other
thing, which is in the
Account Chooser, you see also I
have access through my Gmail
account here.
Now, if I click on that one, it
says, oops, I haven't been
there before.
So Google pops up and
says, is it OK to do
this with this account?
And I say, yeah, sure,
that's OK.
And it goes back to
Account Chooser.
Now, if you look carefully at
the fine print here, it says,
we don't know your
favorite color.
So we're picking
one at random.
So what I was showing
you there was not
one click sign in.
It was one click sign up, which
is starting to become
possible with the combination
of identity providers and
front end technology like
Account Choosers.
Now, we're not there yet.
Account Chooser is available.
We're still working on
technologies to get it better
bootstrapped for a better
end user experience.
But it's really starting to
be a potential reality.
So we do make process.
ERIC SACHS: Yes.
And so one of the key things
that Tim mentioned is while
this works great, once your
website is in this future
world with identity providers,
think about a website who's
still doing everything
with passwords.
A user comes to a site
like this one.
They click an email address that
the operating system, the
browser, whatever it is, and
there are cross platform ways
to do this, knows
are frequently
used on this device.
The user clicks their
email address.
That email address comes
to this website.
And now your website gets
to start being smart.
The first thing it can do is
say, oh, I've seen that email
address before.
So let me ask the user
for a password.
Or it can say, well, I haven't
seen it before.
So let me show a sign-up form.
Let me pre-fill the email
address and get the user to
fill it out.
So all of a sudden, you've at
least avoided the need for the
user to remember sign in, to
sign up, and you've avoided
the need for them to retype
the email address, which
especially on mobile devices,
is a huge win.
It ends up this is a very
small amount of work for
websites to get deployed.
And I think Tim can
speak to that.
However, what really becomes
powerful is now you get to do
what we call percentage
experiments, controlled
experiments with identity
providers.
Where what you could
do on your website,
say, you know what?
Let me pick all the users who
are, say, Gmail email
addresses who start with the
letter A. And any time one
comes to our website and clicks
an email address that
meets that criteria, then I'm
going to do as Tim described.
I'm going to bounce them over
to Google, use Google as an
identity provider, and
bring them back.
And I was mentioning before that
the industry as a whole
is working to the user
experience, the technology,
Google supports the latest
versions of OpenID Connect.
And in fact, in that, there's
this optimization we have
where the website can say, hm,
I already know the email
address the user is using.
So let me start a flow
with Google.
And tell them, hey, I already
got the user's email address.
I just want to know whether that
email address is logged
in here. yes or no,
[? nothing like ?] that.
And that's what Google
responds back.
We just respond back to
the website yes or no.
And if the website sees yes,
then it says, oh, OK.
Well, the user clicked the email
address they wanted.
I know they're logged into
that email address.
Let me just log them in.
There's no user experience
change for users here.
They just go to the site, click
the account they want.
And instead of being asked for a
password and then logged in,
they're just logged in.
So you can do this with, say,
a small percentage of users.
And start to see, OK,
does it impact other
parts of your website?
And then you can try to, say,
delete passwords from some of
those users.
And you'll probably find
things in your
website that do break.
Your mobile apps might be hard
coded for passwords.
Your account management page
might be hard coded for that.
And you can go and start
tracking those things down,
fix them, get it changed.
And then, over time, add support
for more fancy things
like identity providers who
are not email providers or
social network providers
or enterprise
providers, et cetera.
And so we believe that most
websites who want to at least
show that they're starting to
get out of the password
business, this is a first
step you can take.
Because as Tim mentioned, for
all you know, next week is the
week that your security guys are
going to tell you you've
been hacked, and you have to
announce to the world that
everybody has to reset
the passwords.
That is huge branch damage.
Somebody's getting fired.
If you can at least show that
you've taken this as a first
step and you're headed in the
right direction, that's a good
level of insurance that you can
buy yourself without doing
as much work and sets you up to
do some of the experiments
we provide as the industry and
the vendors in this space try
to work to make it easier and
easier for websites to make
this happen.
TIM BRAY: So we kind of know
what the future looks like.
And we are actually providing
something of an on ramp.
Start working here, and that's
where you'll get there.
One thing we're saying is that
while Google is standardizing
on OpenID Connect, this
technology we've been showing
you would work with a legacy
provider that uses SAML, or if
they were using Mozilla Persona
or something like
that, it would all fit
together that way.
ERIC SACHS: Yup.
TIM BRAY: So that's kind of a
snapshot of where we are.
Frankly, we're not in a terribly
good situation.
But I think we do have a pretty
clear vision of where
we need to get to and
the first few steps
to take to get there.
So I think that's about all we
were going to say today.
Do we have any questions there
that we should be looking at
from people watching
out there?
Nothing really?
ERIC SACHS: All right.
TIM BRAY: OK.
ERIC SACHS: They're all going
to take our advice.
TIM BRAY: That's great.
ERIC SACHS: I'd say one last
piece of advice is to say if
you're listening to this,
hopefully you have some of
your own ideas in this.
And a lot of the work in this
area are done in organizations
like the OpenID Foundation, like
these OAuth Community,
OpenID Connect Community,
accountchooser.net working
group, et cetera.
All these groups are looking
for feedback, in particular
from websites to tell us what
is hard for them, what is
keeping them from getting out
of the password business.
We spent a lot of time the last
few years running events
all over the world to collect
feedback from websites about
what it takes to get them
out of that business.
We think we've identified the
key problems, the key themes.
But if there are some issues
we didn't talk about here,
please take a look at some
of these resources on
accountchooser.net, openid.net,
et cetera.
And let us know either your
suggestions how to do it
better, or what are some of the
problem that we haven't
solved that we should
as an industry.
TIM BRAY: Because we haven't
solved all the problems yet.
ERIC SACHS: Nope, not yet.
TIM BRAY: Lots more left.
Thank you, everybody.
ERIC SACHS: Bye-bye.